at these games we are setting up with an
interview with our winner from Group B
Felix blauberger who won the tournament
in a very dominant fashion we're having
very congratulations on your Victory you
had such a strong performance thank you
um so we can't talk about this game you
can take us through some of the key
moments did you ever feel like you were
under pressure or was it it was really
complicated like he gave
upon he sacrificed the pawn some were in
the middle game yes which I didn't
expect at all what were you expecting
here just something maybe bishop B5
because now rookie 3 probably doesn't
work because of G4 I thought
um this looks very scary right maybe 25
King H1
I don't know but I'm kind of
underdeveloped so it's
uh yeah I was calculating Bishop B5
Bishop D7 and some position like this
where I exchange he plays maybe E4
Knight D4
um take only seven and something like
this I thought I should be fine for sure
yeah because it's been on the structure
we never we never see this Knight on
before so it's such a strong piece but
uh things became very concrete when we
went Bishop D3 yeah Bishop D3 and I
think I have to take otherwise he kind
of consolidates Rook A1 and then I'm
probably worse
um so yeah I took and
I'm sorry
yeah that was first I have to go back
with the Knight
um
and queen F4 was also logical and here I
I spent a lot of time because there were
I was calculating G6 also because this
looks logical but I was kind of scared
because of some 94 jumps uh threatening
G4
um so I played the more solid I would
say Knight D4 and calculated kind of
what happened in the game I don't know
how it is objectively but oh objectively
actually it's all correct at least
according to this engine but coming into
this round uh what was your preparation
like were you because you knew if you
draw you secure the title so we're
trying to be more solid or do you just
that I'm just going to play the same way
I've been playing yeah I think I've been
playing solid anyway at least I hope so
and I just wanted to to keep that
strategy I don't take any unnecessary
risks um and just play how I how I have
and I think it works out pretty well
and so you played 94 Bishop went to five
so you took on D6 yeah this was all this
was all pretty concrete so I kind of had
to calculate this all before I played 94
because if it doesn't work uh like this
queen C7 then I'm probably busted yeah
so actually let me so in this position
so you spent half an hour on this move
and yeah here this is force so this one
you spent five minutes
but it goes all the way to here and here
rookie 3 is still I think the only move
yeah that works so so everything worked
out well for you so Queen
actually instead of rookie three there
was something nice uh to calculate it
was Bishop D3 Knight d8 and Knight D2L
but here's King F2 and ah because every
other movie takes yeah even there it's
kind of continued uh because Queen E7 he
has Queen B8 so that's kind of his
it's good it's good it's okay
um okay so you did not go for this
lettering Checkmate too and rookie three
and then all this and here also you're
spending a bit of time so were you
considering F6 maybe yeah but it looks a
bit uh weakening somehow like even then
he just goes Queen G4 and if I take then
he has some checks and
I didn't see the reason so you took and
and then you played rookie three and
we're actually wondering if you give
rue4 is a possibility but understandably
there is some threads on the e-file but
this Pawn is also quite weak and it's
possible that he cannot hang on to this
yeah did you consider this
a bit down but I just thought I will
again like I've played solid and uh
don't allow any tricks but it's
for sure possible he also told me after
the game that Rook D4 he was a bit
worried about and I might be pushing
yeah Queenie it is important
but there are some tricks like Queen G5
here uh Queen G5 yeah but oh yeah here
it doesn't quite work out I think here
you have a F6 I have yeah we need 5g6
yeah but with low time I was a bit uh
hesitant to play like that yeah and then
what happened in the game everything
you wanted yeah it was actually
optimistic in this end game but B4 I
think is pretty strong because if I
managed to bring my king to D6 then he's
under quite some pressure but I think B4
equalized
on the spot and all of this happened and
of course you reached move 40 and you
agreed to a drop yeah so
and yesterday you were playing against
Jason and that was you're playing for
the title so we were Point ahead and
you're out actually again under quite a
bit of pressure how did you feel about
that game yeah yesterday we'll see if I
can pull up this yesterday was pretty
crazy
um let's see if I can find this it must
be in front of me I don't see it okay
yeah so how did you feel about
yesterday's game uh first of all he
surprised me in the opening because uh
he usually went for this love uh but
against me I guess he prepared something
that's why I went just 2d3 to get him
out of the theory uh and then we just
got some normal position but later I
mean he played very fast and very
confident and at some point it kind of
escalated so when where so the first
time we saw the position was uh when uh
when he had already no first position we
saw was this one
this one
and so how did you feel around here
not so well to be honest like I was I
was low on time I at like 10 minutes he
had 40 minutes I think the queen is
completely out of place uh I think there
was also some F4 for him that was
concretely almost winning at some point
but somehow I survived this and I think
later I was maybe even better yeah you
reached this kind of end game and how
did you feel about this end games
because this looked very scary for you
as well yeah I think the computer gives
some Edge for white but on the board
yeah it doesn't feel at all like that
that's why I also exchanged Queens which
is probably also not a great decision
but uh
it turned out to be a draw somehow in
the end so so where did you feel already
comfortable in this game that you
thought
you're out of danger and
it was going to grow until when you
shook hands you're like okay yeah it was
finally until we shook hands I think
that was the moment where I I was
confident that it's a draw yeah this was
a very tense game and of course you had
a great Fighting Chance so it was great
for us to see that so what are the rest
of your plans do are you playing any
other tournaments in the US
no it's it's not planned uh I'm mostly
playing in Europe some some leagues uh
and working as a coach working as a
second so oh it's a second too who I
think that's haricus oh really okay so
that's
for you and are you easy preparing for
something for World Cup or yeah World
Cup uh could be that he he will play but
also the Prague Masters which won last
year
and some some other events too okay well
we wish you best of luck in
future tournaments and as a second and
congratulations again on winning this
tournament and we hope to see you back
here playing in St Louis again thank you
me too and that was the winner of Group
B
and he won the tournament with a
dominant score collecting the first
place four thousand dollars and while
we're